the other thing that really favors
neuroplasticity are what are called Gap
effects anytime you're learning
something
it pays to have random intervals in
which you stop and do nothing you're
practicing a scale you're practicing a
piece of music every once in a while if
you have a timer that goes off randomly
or the instructor or teacher tells you
stop and you attempt to do nothing you
can close your eyes or keep them open
but you stop the motor pattern or you
stop trying to do the math problem or
you stop trying to do the physical
sequence that you were doing turns out
that when we sleep there's a rapid
replay of these sequences that of events
during the day but at much higher speed
so per unit time you're getting about 10
to 60 times the replay or repetition of
what you're doing during the day during
these brief gaps these 10 second gaps
that are introduced while awake during
your learning you get a 10 to 20 times
repeat of whatever sequence you were
trying to learn so this is a way of
getting more repetitions in even though
you're doing less